hey guys this is des the founder thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of boardwalk empire season
4 episode 7 william williamson get a
better go on Poe story time yeah so
let's start off with with Nucky you know
Nucky's the main character of this
entire series however he wasn't in this
episode that much no you know we had the
thing with with Eli in the beginning
about about the handkerchief and like he
was suspicious he went to a Stephen
roots character and and said you know
can you investigate this which later we
found out he was this kind of guy who
seems to have his hands and everything
is actually under the control of the
government cuz he's about to go he's in
danger of going to jail if he doesn't
cooperate yeah with that Oliver alright
Talia um and then also the I think the
main thing that Nucky was part of though
was with his nephew yo Willy Eli son
that whole thing that happened like he
will ease like all guilt feeling guilty
over yeah getting his roommate basically
sent to jail another girl empo doesn't
help with that either yeah yeah yeah and
you know gets matted the girl he's like
dating or sleeping with and and drops
out of school and man that scene was
intense with Eli yeah I mean those those
powerful and he just went after him I
mean went after his son like you just
knew that was that was escalated that he
was gonna because he was talking back to
him you know and here's here's Eli think
I'm paying all this money I'm risking my
life to put you to this nice school and
he know he doesn't know anything about
the whole you know accidentally killing
that guy right so he's thinking what you
know why is my son a wimp you know I
just a week why is he you know such a
like a you know ungrateful son you know
and you just like that I kill the kid on
accident trying to play joke but I kill
them yeah this is one of the few
episodes to which I like so much about
work almost with the exception if I
guess Van Alden touched every single
major character from the show we got you
got to Narcisse we got chalky we got
everybody except for except for Van
Alden pretty much you got almost all the
main characters we even got a little
special appearance you know
from roasting which was cool I was
expecting to see him in the scene with
Mario because I was wondering how they
were gonna lead like why were they
showing this thing with Margaret at her
work who knows a shady deal yes but he's
so he's such a smart business guy well
he's a gambler yeah so he's gambling I
wonder what he's working on what kind
there so sorry angle I mean he's not his
name he's not saying oh ross damn he's
saying he's you know what does he say
his name was oh my god i'll be they both
had different names i like the
conversation at the end they're like
look it's beneficial for both of us if
we don't you know reveal our real name
so let's just you know hey we never saw
each other basically and then with that
that Tolliver guy we get to see like his
his jealousy and frustration of j edgar
basically stealing his whole idea of
this this taking down commander erm yeah
this bigger ring i mean i like that i
like that you know J Edgar's kind of
slides he's like this you know the guys
introducing him is like this Oh standing
man with moral vigor it's like well we
kind of know jeguk story the guys kind
of shade he's got a little weird things
going on but it's good I liked you I
like the jagers even in this season
that's really usually the people who are
you know you know it's just like in
regular like the people who who are the
moral police right the people who always
like this is wrong and this is you know
and the most adamant about going after
people always have the most to hide
right exactly so that's really I mean
it's just so much going on I mean like I
said there's so much to talk about this
episode I mean we even look at that nice
a little scene with you know Charlie
Luciano Lucky Luciano with his boss who
knows about what happened in Tampa no
surprise there but looks like he's gonna
go back to Tampa to make you deal with
heroin I don't think Nucky one lucky
doesn't to mess with with heroin there's
not he's not into the run in the drug
business so I mean that's gonna be and
his boss Joe Joe Masseria he he's
basically saying oh no you we didn't
forgive Nucky we took the money right
but were you know that that's not over
so so I think Lucky's privy to that but
he I think he just wants to keep his
boss happy and stay in the way yeah I
mean he's got to make his rise some time
but yeah right now he's just happy to
keep enjoying plus he showed that he was
loyal yeah by not being in business
yeah no yeah and then we had Jillian
yeah Justin you know she's rehabbing she
seems to be she's found a new man yeah
you happiness everything's happy we know
that's not gonna end well no it's I mean
it's nice that she's getting off the the
heroin the smack but we still don't know
what his intentions are no we don't we
don't know what his motives are what is
he doing there I mean why is he even
there I don't get it he's just I mean
I've got it on the show I think living
cents a great actor but it's just funny
Jesus like who is this guy what does he
want okay and then also we get a Al
Capone who's been he's trying to get
Torrio to like make moves on obeying and
he doesn't want to do it because you
don't want to wreck this deal and
whatnot but then the deal goes south
yeah so do you think that Al Capone put
in the word to the police to have the
police come and to make it look like
O'Banion was doing or was it or is
O'Banion actually really behind this
this this I think O'Banion's behind it i
just think Torrio's kind of it he's
until the very end I thought he's just
being a pushover I kind of pushover for
a long time ever he got back from that
trip from Italy I think last season he
somewhat Italy how great it was and he's
just kind of out of the game I was like
okay now it's time for Capone to step up
but I think that it was so obvious that
even he could see I don't know it's a
good question it could be it could be
Capone I mean Capone you know he wants
to go after he thinks O'Banion did I
mean maybe he did and didn't we don't
know huh so now basically gave the green
light to Helen said no you can start
this war right now Torrio want some bout
20 want some dads yeah it's on now so
yeah we didn't see Van Alden in this but
I'm assuming in the next few episodes
with right yeah he'll factor in he'll be
playing both sides in between not
knowing what's going on poor guy now we
have this whole thing with a dr.
Narcisse and chalky you know Chuck he's
like in lust or love with the singer and
learns about her background she tells
that story about how she saw her mom
killed how her mom was a prostitute and
of course at the end we find out that
the person that killed her was dr. and I
see so that's so weird
I wait so the whole person who killed
your mother your affectionate towards
I'm like it's weird yeah she's like
loyal to ya and basically she's just a
spy she's you know she was sent there to
seduce chalky find out information and
tell him and I hope chalky comes out of
this cuz like I like Chuck I think he's
a smart guy but he's getting played
right now yeah I mean doctor she's like
oh do you mind if I set up this little
thing I have going it's like wait no
deals that easy you're not going to hit
his number one star his girl that easily
by just opening up some boys club met
metaphor basically and then when he went
to the church he started kind of
preaching and you know getting everyone
behind him instead of chalky right and
then of course he did the whole thing
where it's like and then me and the
Deacon over there gonna rid you know and
then of course Don purnsley uh takes a
mound it at the end Egan's last two
deacons like wait a minute on the what
all those yeah but don't you think like
sooner or later that the people are
gonna find out that dr. Narcisse is
behind this or do you think it's just
gonna fall out like Don pern's Lisa door
I think is gonna fall head so I think he
is using him like a puppet I think cuz I
mean Donnie's you know he's he's
basically he's easily you know he's the
button man I guess he pushes people's
buttons but I don't don't think he's
more than that so I think he is just
gonna be used right now and I don't know
i mean i wonder if Chalky's gonna come
help him they don't have a good
relationship I don't know I I hate
seeing talking get play that's what I
hate seeing talking via plagues of
chalky so I'm like chalky stop messing
with a girl and then open your eyes and
see what's going on right now so yeah
this is another episode where a lot of
pieces are moving you know I've noticed
like the last episode in this episode
have been almost an hour long yeah well
I oh yeah you see the episodes are about
52 right maybe sometimes 48 right like
that but yeah these are they're really
putting in setting up something you know
so the curse of this i'm not sure what
direction we're gonna go mean
everybody's got so many like this
episode was just packed with so many
things is one of the first time we've
seen all the character at the same time
so it's good it's gonna it's gonna be
good good conclusion as a season keeps
me yeah we haven't even factored it at
least in this episode there wasn't like
that much tampa stuff they talked about
it but like we see in the preview for
next week yeah Patricia Arquette's
character coming
up in there there's gonna be a whole
whole mess of stuff yeah absolutely good
alright guys so let's know what you
thought of the episode you can post your
comments below on the website to CARICOM
or on our youtube channel thats pink
hero pro which you can also subscribe to
also come to all those on Twitter I
Dennis and I Oh or all at think hero
personally i'm at griffin de and we have
a Facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think hero fans
you